sure but that was an idea we had  um and then I was gonna do I'm gonna go  to this girl in Florida where she lives  like so oh my gosh I I couldn't live  like that like she's crazy traditional  like she like does her laundry by hand  but I'm gonna like live like her for a  week and see how it goes nice  um  yeah  so is that something you aspire to  though to be so traditional that you're  doing laundry by hand it seems like a  massive waste of time no I won't be that  true no I mean I just it's more just  about the whole point of the series is  to listen to what men want and try to be  more of what men want so that's that's  the whole point is it like to do laundry  by hand no but like sometimes you learn  like how to make something  like I don't know I didn't realize like  how how much men value cooking and even  like I'm in my dad like a cake from  scratch he was just he like thought it  was the sweetest thing